While The Rise of Skywalker answered a number
of the saga's lingering questions, it also
presented a few of its own.
We can't promise you'll understand every part
of Episode IX after delving into our explanations,
but we hope we can help you feel at least
a little less confused.
The Rise of Skywalker wastes no time in telling
us that Sheev Palpatine, the Emperor from
the original trilogy that we all presumed
was dead after the end of Return of the Jedi,
is actually alive.
In fact, Palpatine has been pulling the strings
of the First Order this whole time.
"The First Order arose from the Dark Side."
While we never get a detailed explanation
for Palpatine's survival, we should've known
better than to assume a fall would kill a
strong Force user like Palpatine, especially
since both Darth Maul and Luke Skywalker survived
pretty serious falls in past Star Wars canon.
After Return of the Jedi, Palpatine slunk
off to the Sith planet of Exegol, where Sith
loyalists used machines to artificially prolong
his life, similar to how Darth Vader was stabilized
after his battle with Obi-Wan in Revenge of
the Sith.
Once on Exegol, Palpatine bided his time in
the shadows, waiting until his fleet was strong
enough to reveal itself.
The opening crawl of Rise of Skywalker mentions
that newly-minted Supreme Leader Kylo Ren
is searching for Palpatine, "determined to
destroy any threat to his power."
The film then reveals Kylo Ren on the surface
of a glowing red planet, slaughtering a forest
full of faceless opponents before ultimately
locating a Sith Wayfinder that once belonged
to his grandfather, Darth Vader.
That Wayfinder reveals the way to Exegol,
where Kylo Ren confronts Palpatine and learns
the truth of Rey's parentage.
The battle for the Wayfinder takes place on
Mustafar, the volcano planet where Anakin
Skywalker once dueled his mentor, Obi-Wan
Kenobi.
This time, Kylo Ren is fighting members of
the Alazmec of Winsit, a cult of Vader-worshipers
guarding his Sith fortress, who also planted
the unlikely forest of irontrees where the
battle takes place.
Unfortunately for the Alazmec, Kylo Ren had
no interest in explaining to them why he needed
to access the ruins of Fortress Vader, and
found it easier to cut a smoldering path through
his grandfather's acolytes than to simply
ask permission to pass.
Palpatine assembles a massive Final Order
fleet before The Rise of Skywalker, but it's
not entirely clear how he does it.
We know that Palpatine was able to channel
the power of all the Sith who had come before
him, that he was cloning Snokes who were also
all presumably strong in the Dark Side of
the Force, and that he had a network of loyalists
he was able to tap into throughout the galaxy,
even after his presumed death.
We also know based on the thousands of shrouded
figures in the throne room that either Exegol
had a large native population that was loyal
to Palpatine, or that he was able to physically
manifest the countless former Sith who resided
within him.
Either way, it seems as though Palpatine had
a large and powerful workforce at his decaying
fingertips, and 30 years of secrecy in which
to build his army.
As for where he acquired the resources to
construct the ships, the Rise of Skywalker
Visual Dictionary confirms that Palpatine
was siphoning supplies from the First Order
through loyalists he had embedded within its
ranks.
Following the death of Luke Skywalker at the
end of The Last Jedi, his twin sister Leia
Organa took it upon herself to train the Force-sensitive
Rey in the ways of the Jedi.
This might come as a bit of a surprise, considering
we never saw Leia receive any Jedi training
herself, despite indications of her Force
sensitivity throughout the Star Wars films.
In The Rise of Skywalker, we learn that when
Leia was younger, she actually did train as
a Jedi with Luke, and essentially completed
her training, even constructing her own lightsaber.
However, on the final day of her training,
Leia had a vision that her Jedi path would
lead to the death of her son, which caused
her to turn away from becoming a Jedi.
So while Leia technically isn't a Jedi herself,
she has all the knowledge, training, and capabilities
necessary to continue Rey's instruction where
her brother had left off.
When the Resistance learns that Palpatine
is alive, they worry that they won't be able
to stop him, since he's on Exegol, and no
one knows how to get there.
However, Rey remembers that Luke Skywalker
had attempted to find Exegol many years earlier.
While Luke hadn't actually found the Sith
planet, he had tracked the Wayfinder that
revealed its location to a desert planet called
Pasaana, where the trail had gone cold.
However, when Rey leads her team to Pasaana,
instead of the Wayfinder, they find another
clue.
It turns out that many years ago, a Sith loyalist
named Ochi was tasked with bringing the young
Rey to Palpatine on Exegol, and he carried
a dagger inscribed with the coordinates of
the Wayfinder.
But before Ochi could find Rey, he accidentally
rode his speeder into the sinking fields of
Pasaana, and died buried beneath the planet's
surface, along with the Sith dagger.
After finding Ochi's Sith dagger, C-3PO reveals
that while he can read the coordinates inscribed
on it, he is incapable of translating them
for the rest of the team.
As Threepio explains, his programming forbids
him from translating the Sith language under
any circumstances due to a rule passed by
the Imperial Senate, which may date all the
way back to the prequels.
As we learned in Episodes One through Three,
Palpatine spent years manipulating the Senate
from within in order to serve his dark purposes,
and eventually dissolved the Senate entirely.
Knowing this, it makes sense that Palpatine
would've enacted legislation making it impossible
for droids to translate Sith, enabling him
to keep his true identity and master plan
hidden from his peers.
When Rey and her friends prepare to leave
Pasaana, Chewbacca gets captured and loaded
onto a transport by First Order troops, while
a horrified Finn looks on.
Concerned, Finn runs to tell Rey, and they
both watch as a transport takes flight from
behind a large rock formation.
Rey tries to use the Force to pull the transport
back to the ground, but after meeting opposition
from Kylo Ren, she becomes frustrated and
lets out a surge of energy that causes the
transport to explode, which she thinks means
that Chewie has died.
Almost immediately, we find out that Chewie
is actually still alive, and is being held
captive on a First Order ship.
General Hux mentions that there was actually
a second First Order transport on Pasaana,
which was the one Finn saw Chewie being loaded
onto.
He must not have seen the second one due to
the rock formations dotting the landscape.
Since Rey, Finn, and their companions left
Pasaana immediately after the transport exploded,
they missed when the second one containing
Chewie took off.
Early on, The Rise of Skywalker sets up the
intriguing mystery of a spy within the First
Order who is passing crucial bits of information
to the Resistance.
This spy is later revealed to be none other
than the sniveling General Hux, much to the
shock of Finn and Poe, who are completely
blindsided by the First Order officer's turn.
After all, Hux spent the entirety of The Force
Awakens and The Last Jedi fervently opposing
the Resistance and fighting to advance the
First Order's agenda.
So what changed?
Based on Hux's explanation to Finn, he still
isn't actually a friend to the Resistance,
and has no investment in their ultimate victory.
But as much as he hates the Resistance, he
hates Kylo Ren more, and seems to have been
motivated to switch sides following Ren's
ascension to Supreme Leader.
When Ren took Snoke's place, Hux was disgusted
to find his power significantly diminished,
and seemed to hope that by aiding the Resistance,
he could topple Kylo Ren and subsequently
seize more power for himself.
Between the completion of The Last Jedi and
the beginning of production on The Rise of
Skywalker, Carrie Fisher, who has played Leia
Organa since A New Hope in 1977, passed away.
However, since Leia was still very much alive
in the Star Wars universe, director J.J. Abrams
announced that he would be reworking The Rise
of Skywalker's storyline to incorporate previously
unused footage of Fisher from The Force Awakens
to finish Leia's journey.
This resulted in Leia being present in the
first act of Rise of Skywalker as Rey's teacher
and the leader of the Resistance, then dying
around the midpoint of the film after reaching
out to her son one final time with the Force.
While Leia's ending was largely dictated by
the available archival footage of Fisher,
her death still provided a bittersweet and
fitting send-off to her character.
Although it appears that Leia only transmits
the name "Ben" through the Force, her son's
reaction indicates that he received more than
that.
Perhaps it isn't only his name that Leia Force-projects
to him, but her feelings of motherly love
and acceptance, letting him know that even
after all he's done, she still considers him
her son.
Leia's last-ditch effort to pull her son back
from the Dark Side pays off, but the effort
of reaching him takes every bit of remaining
strength she has.
She dies, becoming one with the Force, just
like her brother before her.
At first glance, it might seem as though Kylo
Ren's transformation back into Ben Solo is
confusingly abrupt.
But upon closer examination, Ben's decision
to abandon his Dark Side persona is something
he's been struggling with for a long time,
both in previous films and in the first half
of The Rise of Skywalker.
Before his duel with Rey, Kylo tells her that
he can never go back to his mother.
The Dark Side is the only option available
to him.
But when Leia contacts him during their duel,
he realizes the truth, he could always go
back, and the only one holding him back was
himself.
Afterward, he imagines his deceased father,
Han Solo, who tells him Kylo Ren is dead,
and counters every argument he can think of
to remain on his dark path.
Finally, when it seems as though Ben wants
to apologize for all the evil he's done, Han
replies with his iconic, "I know," communicating
his enduring love and forgiveness.
Afterward, Ben tosses his Sith lightsaber
into the ocean, having finally found the strength
to turn back to the Light Side thanks to the
combined efforts of his loving parents.
Long before the beginning of The Force Awakens,
Palpatine was responsible for the creation
of Snoke, along with an indeterminate number
of identical Snoke clones.
Palpatine maneuvered Snoke into a position
of power as Supreme Leader of the First Order,
and all of Snoke's orders in the first two
films actually came from Palpatine.
While Palpatine was secretly shaping the First
Order, he was also searching for his granddaughter,
Rey, whom he considered his heir.
He sent out bounty hunters to find her, but
their efforts failed.
He didn't know where she was until she started
her Force training under Luke Skywalker.
He then tasked Kylo Ren with finding and killing
her, but he never intended for him to succeed.
Instead, he hoped his efforts would propel
Rey to lean further into the Dark Side, preparing
her to take over for Palpatine as Empress.
Once Rey faced him on Exegol, Palpatine tempted
her to strike him down and take his place,
just as he once taunted Luke Skywalker.
Palpatine claimed that killing him would transfer
his spirit to Rey, along with all the past
Sith, and they would all rule over the galaxy
as one.
After Palpatine believes he's won, Rey again
attempts the Force exercise that's been eluding
her throughout the whole film, trying to channel
the Jedi who have come before her.
This time, it works, and Rey is strengthened
by a number of Jedi voices feeding her encouragement
that enables her to face Palpatine again.
If some of those voices sounded familiar,
there's a reason for that.
The Rise of Skywalker brings back every significant
Jedi from past Star Wars movies, including
Hayden Christensen as Anakin Skywalker, Ewan
McGregor and Alec Guinness as Obi-Wan Kenobi,
Liam Neeson as Qui-Gon Jinn, Frank Oz as Yoda,
Samuel L. Jackson as Mace Windu, and of course,
Mark Hamill as Luke Skywalker.
Additionally, the scene includes voice actors
from Star Wars animated series who portrayed
now-deceased Jedi, namely Ashley Eckstein
as Ahsoka Tano, Freddie Prinze Jr. as Kanan
Jarrus, Olivia D'Abo as Luminara Unduli, Jennifer
Hale as Aayla Secura, and Angelique Perrin
as Adi Gallia.
The combined strength of Rey and the spirits
of the past Jedi is enough for Rey to reflect
Palpatine's Dark energy back on himself, killing
him.
Since Palpatine technically causes his own
death, his spirit doesn't pass to Rey as he'd
planned, and the Sith line is ended.
"No.
No.
You will die!"
Several times throughout The Rise of Skywalker,
characters mention that Rey and Kylo Ren make
up a "dyad in the Force," a new term we've
never heard in previous Star Wars films.
Dyads are extremely rare, and the two of them
together can wield the Force in powerful ways
that haven't been seen in generations.
Kylo Ren speculates that their unique nature
is due to them being the grandchildren of
two of the greatest Force-users in history,
Anakin Skywalker and Emperor Palpatine.
When Palpatine realizes that Rey and Ben are
stronger together than either of them are
separately, he heals his decrepit body by
draining their combined Force energy, then
tries to weaken them by splitting them up.
Rey is still able to defeat Palpatine by channeling
the strength of past Jedi, but the effort
completely drains and kills her.
However, Ben is able to revive Rey by transferring
all of his energy to her through the Force,
which ultimately kills him.
Before he dies, though, he and Rey are able
to share a few grateful moments of life together,
likely made possible by the strength of their
shared bond.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.